hello everyone so what i want to talk
about here is how to interpret the
directional derivative in terms of
graphs so i have here the graph of a
function a multivariable function
it's f of x y
is equal to x squared times y
in the last couple of videos i talked
about what the directional derivative is
how you can formally define it how you
compute it using the gradient and
generally the way that you
the the setup that you might have is
you'll have some kind of vector and this
is a vector in the input space so in
this case it's going to be in the x y
plane
um in this case i'll just take the
vector
uh
i'll take the vector 1 1.
okay
and the directional derivative which we
denote by kind of taking the gradient
symbol except you stick that stick the
name of that vector down in the lower
part there
the directional derivative of your
function
it'll still take the same inputs this is
kind of a measure of how the function
changes when the input moves in that
direction so i'll show you what i mean i
mean
you can imagine slicing this graph
by
by some kind of plane
but that plane
doesn't necessarily have to be parallel
to the x or y axes you know that's what
we did for the partial derivative we'd
take a plane that represented a constant
x value or a constant y value but this
is going to be a plane that kind of
tells you what movement in the direction
of your vector looks like and like like
i have a number of other times i'm going
to go ahead and slice the graph along
that plane
and just to make just to make it clear
i'm
going to
color in
where the graph intersects that slice
and this vector here this little v you'd
be thinking of as living on the x y
plane
and it's it's determining the direction
of of this plane that we're slicing
things with so on the xy plane you've
got this vector it's one one it kind of
points in that diagonal direction and
you take the whole plane and you slice
your graph
and if we want to interpret the the
directional derivative here
of i'm going to go ahead and fill in an
actual value so let's say we wanted to
do it at like negative 1 1
negative 1 negative 1 because i guess i
chose a plane that passes through the
origin so i've got to make sure that
the point i'm evaluating it actually
goes along this plane but you could
imagine one that points in the same
direction but you kind of slide it back
and forth
so
if we're doing this
we can interpret this as a slope but you
have to be very careful if you're going
to interpret this as a slope it has to
be the case that you're dealing with a
unit vector that the magnitude of your
vector is equal to 1. i mean it doesn't
have to be you can kind of account for
it later but it makes it more easy to
think about if we're just thinking of a
unit vector so when i go over here
instead of saying that it's 1 1
i'm going to say it's whatever vector
points in that same direction but it has
a unit length and in this case
that happens to be square root of 2 over
2
for each of the components and you can
kind of think about
why that would be true pythagorean
theorem and all but this is a vector
with unit length it's it's
its magnitude is 1 and it points in that
direction and if we're evaluating this
at a point like negative 1 1 we can draw
that on the graph see where it actually
is
and in this case it'll be
moving things about when i add a point
it'll be this point here and you kind of
look from above you say okay that is
kind of negative 1 negative 1
and if we want the slope at that point
you're kind of thinking of the tangent
line here tangent line to that curve and
we're wondering what its slope is
so
the reason that the directional
derivative is going to give us this
slope is because if you think about this
another notation that might be kind of
helpful for what this directional
derivative is
some people will write partial f and
then partial v
and you know you could think about that
as taking a slight nudge in the
direction of v right so this would be a
little nudge
a little partial nudge in the direction
of v and then you're saying
what what change in the value of the
function does that result in you know
the height of the graph tells you the
value of the function and as this
initial change approaches zero and the
resulting change approaches zero as well
that ratio the ratio of the f to or
partial f to partial v is going to give
you the slope of this tangent line
so conceptually that's kind of a nicer
notation but the reason we use this
other notation this nabla sub v one is
it's very indicative of how you compute
things
once you need to compute it you take the
gradient of f
just the vector valued function gradient
of f and take the dot product with your
vector
with the vector
so let's actually do that just to just
to see what this would look like and
i'll go ahead and write it over here
i'll use a use a different color so the
gradient of f first of all
gradient of f is a vector full of
partial derivatives
so it'll be the partial derivative of f
with respect to x
and the partial derivative of f with
respect to y
and when we actually evaluate this we
take a look partial derivative of f with
respect to x x looks like the variable y
is just a constant so its partial
derivative is 2 times x times y
2 times x times y but when we take the
partial with respect to y
y now looks like a variable x looks like
a constant derivative of a constant
times the variable is just that constant
x squared
and if we were to evaluate this at the
point negative 1 negative 1
now you could plug that in
2 times negative 1 times negative 1
would be 2
and then negative square negative 1
squared would be 1.
so that would be our gradient at that
point
which means if we want to evaluate
gradient of f times v
we could go over here
and say that that's 2 1
because we you know we evaluate the
gradient at the point we care about
and then the dot product with v itself
in this case
root two over two
and root two over two
the answer that we'd get we multiply the
first two components together two times
root two over two
the square root of two
and then here we multiply the second
components together
and that's going to be one times root
two over two
root two over two and that would be our
answer that would be our slope
but this only works if your vector is a
is a unit vector because and i showed
this in the last video where we talked
about the formal definition of the
partial of the directional derivative if
you scale v by 2 and i could do it here
if instead of v you're talking about 2v
so i'll go ahead and make myself some
room here
if you're taking the directional
derivative along 2v
of f
the way that we're computing that you're
taking still taking the gradient
of f
dot product
with 2 times your vector
and dot products you can you can pull
out that too
this is just going to double the value
of the entire thing
of v
of this dotted with v
it's going to be twice the value the
derivative will become twice the value
but you don't necessarily want that
because you'd say this plane that you
slice it with if instead of doing it in
the direction of you know v the unit
vector you did it in the direction of
two times v
it's the same plane it's the same slice
you're taking and you'd want that same
slope so that's going to mess everything
up so this is super important if you're
thinking about things in the context of
slope one thing that you could say is
your you know formula for the slope of a
slope of a graph in the direction of v
is you take your directional derivative
that dot product between f and v and you
just always make sure to divide it by
the magnitude of v
you know divide it by that magnitude and
that'll always take care of what you
want that's basically a way of making
sure that really you're taking the
directional derivative in the direction
of a certain unit vector
some people even go so far as to define
the directional derivative to be this to
be something where you normalize out the
length of that vector i don't i don't
really like that um but i think that's
that's because they're thinking of the
slope context they're thinking of
you know
rates of change as being the slope of a
graph
and one thing i'd like to emphasize as
always graphical intuition is good and
visual intuition is always great you
should always be trying to find a way to
think about things visually but with
multi-variable functions the graph isn't
the only way
you can kind of more more generally
think about just a nudge in the in the v
direction and in the context where v
doesn't have a length one you know the
nudge doesn't represent an actual size
but it's a certain scaling constant
times that vector you can look at the
video on the formal definition for the
directional derivative if you want more
details on that but i do but i do think
this is actually a good way to get a
feel for what the directional derivative
is all about